foreign
[Music]
before we wrap up I'm just going to do a
really quick try not to laugh
I really enjoyed the last one really
really quick I'm not as many as I have
like I did last time okay
um obviously dark humor
this is for all of you by the way
all of you try not to laugh I didn't do
very well last week I don't think but
anyway you did good you didn't do that
you didn't do that I laughed for a lot
um there's something
maybe like three or four okay go all
right say this I'm not laughing at any
today
right
why do black people
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're a waste man hold on bro oh three
words yeah I literally said three words
why do black people have nightmares
go on
because we shot the last one who had a
dream
that is dark
yeah that's really dark
Jesus
wow okay cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool cool cool
are you ready for the next one ready I'm
ready I'm ready these are dog these are
five dark ones sounds like it
my girlfriend called me a pedophile and
I said that's a big word for a fight
stops
wow my girlfriend
that's not even funny bro oh Jesus
three more three more three more
and this isn't enough Watts by the way
yeah he's fine your laugh makes me laugh
what did the kid with no arms and legs
get for Christmas
I don't know fiad
cancer
is it yeah
you're good I'm not laughing at that I'm
good man
that's disgusting all right two two more
to go come on a black man
a Mexican oh God and a Puerto Rican are
all in the car
who's driving
the police
that was wrong last one cool
bought my son a trampoline for his
birthday
The Ungrateful [__] just sat in his
wheelchair and cried
[Laughter]
that's disgraceful bro
wow wow
[Music]
wow wow wow wow okay yeah that was wrong
yeah Reddit come up with some dark [__]
bro that was already yeah reddit's dis
gusting that was already because I can't
find any new juicy dark Hue machine well
if they're all recycled yeah yeah it's
all of these red is going to give you
disgraceful disgraceful stuff that is a
different level that was a different
level bro wow Fair Play That's well the
first one I said I was like why do black
people upset me because I knew it was
going to be
I knew's gonna be twisted
that's hilarious yeah okay fair enough
well guys I'm gonna wrap the episode
there at the end thank you thank you
very much um paying Thursday as always
we'll see you on Monday love love
[Music]
foreign